Black Panther is clawing his way onto
the big screen and Marvel's Captain
America Civil War if you're wondering
who this cat clad hero is and where he
came from we've got you covered
Black Panthers real name is touch Allah
and he comes from the African nation of
Wakanda the Black Panther guys is a
ceremonial title given to the ruler of
the nation even though it is a
birthright ceremonial trials must be
passed in order to become the Black
Panther once becoming the chieftain a
special heart shape herb is consumed
along with a mystical connection to the
Panther God the Black Panther gains
superhuman abilities including
heightened strength stamina agility
speed healing reflexes and senses what
Conda appears to be a jungle nation but
it is also a place of extreme wealth and
Technology the country's wealth comes
from having the largest deposit of
vibranium in the world vibranium is a
sound and impact absorbing mineral which
is present in Captain America's
indestructible shield
in the movie Black Panthers costume also
contains the element black panther first
appeared in comics in 1966 Fantastic
Four number 52 he invited a team to his
country and immediately launched an
attack upon them using his skills and
intellect he was able to single-handedly
take on the entire team the challahs
reason for an attack was to ensure he
was ready to take on the villain Klaw
over the years too Chawla has been
involved in and won several fights with
both heroes and villains in the Marvel
Universe Ulysses Klaw was seen in the
movies in Avengers age of Ultron the
comic version killed Black Panthers
father King takaka when T'Challa was a
child in the movie it's rumored that the
Panther is led to believe someone else
is responsible for his father's death
which gives him a reason to join Tony
Stark's side of the fight he adds quite
a bit to Iron Man's team and is sure to
give his opponents a bite they'll never
forget we can catch the action in
Captain America Civil War and black
panther will also star in his own film
in February 2018
you
you